háháhá
o psol decidiu dar mais um vídeo e hoje
fazer uma coisa que você sempre buscando
que continuarão conselho das armas do
papel
só que chegou um momento em que elas são
bastante parecidas tem sempre esse
aspecto popular então pensei vai ser
aqui uns diazinhos querer dois dias para
melhorar estas armas aqui e fazer elas
mais partidas colegiais mais eficientes
mais resistentes com um mecanismo que
tive enfrenta a partir de agora só vão
ser montado papel mutado cartão e os
tempos vocês vão encontrar na página do
facebook o primeiro link de inscrição na
seleção das fotografias vocês vão lá em
primeiras folhas ea partir daí vai ser
muito mais fácil em comparação com os
vídeos antigos que vocês vão colar muita
coisa bastante positivo depois de
ensinar como fazer uma transmissão
semi-automática e agora estou a
trabalhar numa automática que já fiz em
3d já consegue fazer um protótipo do
protótipo santo em papel e cartão mas
funciona em 3d então não aumente
funciona também então só apanhei daí
vocês curtirem não digam o que vocês
acham os comentários e agora vamos
começar com o tutorial para fazer isto
dizer que foi escutar manhã a 3 e cola
pva caso vocês não tenham folhas de
cinco grandes podem usar folhas a4 ou
seja se juntar em duas folhas com o
tamanho a4 vamos ter uma folha com o
tamanho a3 e depois é só fazer tudo como
vocês estão vendo vídeo para fazer um
diâmetro de outubro utilizei como
referência este pedaço de um clube e
mais tarde eu vou usar eu para fazer o
pistão da cunha o rio cola na borda e
depois deslizem espalhar para
interromper a entrevista no início do
vídeo vou precisar de um tempo aí que
vocês vão encontrar carga no primeiro
link de inscrição pois tem que juntar as
duas partes a fita ou então cobre as
partes
vocês vão encontrar lá desenhados por
ser mais fácil trabalhar do seguida com
esta parte usando fita e tem fita porque
os cidadãos a fazer com outro modo igual
então é só escolar com muito cuidado e
colar em outra parte da população acham
que eu usei uma caneta quer ver com
força para fazer a marcação no cartão
depois tem que usar uma caneta um lápis
para fazer um traço em cima da marcação
que vocês fizeram para ser mais fácil
depois de cortar para isso usa um x ato
que parece que o dos médicos vai fazer a
parte cinzenta precisado da sua opinião
mais resistente para isso usa um doce
escolar que os anúncios mas o processo é
bastante identificado com vocês viram
anteriormente a única diferença é que
vocês vão ter mais dificuldade em
executar porque o plano vai ser mais
resistente e caso vocês sejam crianças
peçam ajuda o duto coloca o esmalte
desta maneira e cobre uma parte pequena
é uma parte grande do molde para isso
usava cola quente vocês podem usar cola
bbva
eu só não quero usar a copa pb há por
que demoram mais tempo as caras sobrepõe
uma parte muito bem ao gol tam e depois
passam furos nos lugares assinalados o
tamanho da bronca tem que ser
ligeiramente maior o tamanho de um
palito de churrasco
quarta um prato no youtube demais homem
de 29 centímetros e cola é 1,5
centímetro da borda da pista e parte vai
dar volume à arma e também vai ajudar a
prender o cano região que eu vou pôr
aqui bastante cola e por um cano porque
não acaba onde é cavar para de 29
centímetros
tiro o chapéu à volta desta peça
equalizando fita um pedaço popular
primeiro tem que contornar a peça por
fora usando uma caneta ou então lápis e
depois usando a mesma folha tem que
fazer uma peça ligeiramente mais pequena
demais enquanto na parta branco e depois
por fora até chegar ao outro lado da
linha
no total vão satisfazer duas peças
grandes e cinco então 6 daquelas
pequenininhas isso vai depender do
tamanho ou seja da espessura do vosso
população
primeiro tem que enfrentar as partes
pequeninas para se usar outra vez colo
quinto vocês podem usar cola tva também
só que vai demorar mais tempo buscar
como disse anteriormente
depois tem que rolar uma parte grande de
um lado e outro do outro lado e sei que
vai ser um detido como você age em las
uma curvatura quando vocês vão pôr o
dedo para finalizar esta peça é só fazer
um furo no lugar marcado
agora fazer uma peça que é responsável
por segurar o pistão vejam cortec o
chefe papel a volta todo deixei só mesmo
desempenho e marcar em pouquinho de
picolé grande
agora se vocês não tiverem não tem
problema nenhum vocês podem usar o mesmo
método que usa anteriormente ou seja em
vez de putin picolé vocês podem usar
população
só que o pai eu ficar mais resistente
que vocês têm que usar uma super cola em
alguns pré e que vai fortificar
população para aguentar mais tempo e
vejo que estou a fazer agora um furo
assim mesmo na outra extremidade que
fica 90 graus com o primeiro muito
importante que vocês façam mais na
marcação aqui porque se vocês não
fizerem quando fez quando por alguma
peça que o passa aquela linha isso
passar a linha depois o gatilho não vai
funcionar
ou seja antes de começar a colocar o
resto da parte da estrutura da arma
importante fazer aquela linha e sim vou
ficar mais disse
cansados que depois não vai dar problema
puseram os tubos tenham cuidado para
eles ficarem dentro do molde elas não
podem seguir para fora porque isso vai
dar problema na hora de colocar a faixa
a volta façam dois furos no sítio onde
vocês fizeram anteriormente para vos
facilitar este processo aqui que vocês
tem que testar o mecanismo tem que estar
o fio desta maneira na parte
semicircular corta um sucesso e depois
cola e do modo que não fique na parte de
cima da peça que ela parta reta sem fio
vejam se funciona o mecanismo funcionará
marca linha do modo que significada e
faça um novo organismo estiver a
funcionar vocês ponham cola nas partes
que vão conectar com moto falta por cima
e fazer isso bem rápido para cola no
oscar entretanto se ficar tudo bem fixo
irã o chefe dos produtos e por uma gota
de cola de cada lado do palito para
finalizar esta parte da arma tem claro
na faixa com a altura da arma
assim a volta ou seja vocês pegam não
gostar é gol enquanto aqui ontem de
altura com a arma estava deitava corta
uma faixa ou duas estruturas oculares
assim a volta
caso vocês querem disfarçar as
transmissões de uma para a população
para a outra
vocês podem fazer é apoiar em cola teve
ainda um pincel e passar várias camadas
nessa parte transição depois quando
tiver bem seco é só vocês pegarem uma
lixa fina e deixarem com muito cuidado e
depois pintarem por cima que depois vai
gastar muito bem vocês nem vão perceber
que ali uma conexão mas depois vou fazer
isso para vocês verem como é que isso
funciona
veja que eu coloquei um passinho à
frente que vai usar encaixar os
elásticos que vocês vão ver mais para
frente eu agora estou cortar pedacinhos
de tubo de caneta precisar de dois
tubinhos de um pedaço de madeira que é
ligeiramente maior que essa parte dos
tubinhos da caneta
vejam como é que eu estou colar
os tubinhos aqui na caneta tem que ficar
30 aquelas duas partes de madeira e eles
ficam mais ou menos a maio daquela parte
de madeira e é mais pequenina um posto
aqui um crime de cola no youtube onde a
opção vai bater só vai ficar mais forte
que usei uma super cola e agora para
obtido ficar a funcionar melhor
ou seja quando vocês por funcionarem
pode parar
bush vai voltar atrás quando vocês
tirarem o dedo então é só por um
elástico nesta quarta e para explicar
que o sindicado exemplo assim população
mas vocês podem por um prego ou então
podem prender usando fita também
importante é que o elástico fica
explicado
nunca tinha já está a funcionar agora só
falta pôr os elásticos no pistão nos
antes de mais óculos de proteção
o encaixar com elástico por dentro de um
tubo de caneta e foi passar o elástico
dentro do próprio elástico explicar bem
e como os meus elásticos não chegavam à
frente então eu decidi acrescentar mais
um seja muito vocês só vão precisar usar
um elástico de cada lado se esticarem
mais ou menos gozadores se esticar um
pouco então vocês podem usar três mas
não como é que você se encaixa elástico
no outro
depois é só fazer esta é a argola
encaixar naquele clima de madeira na
frenta para ficar estabilizada é muito
importante vocês podem mesmo número de
latinos de um lado e do outro e agora
está na hora do texto para te falar eu
vou usar e que uma bola de papel que
vocês não saibam como fazer é só vocês
passaram pelo meu canal que eu vou
encontrar um vídeo em que eu vou ensinar
fazer isso aí mas é bastante simples
cagaram mas só vocês fecharam questão
para trás e tudo aquilo vai
automaticamente para a sua posição
somente filhos para com um balanço do
papel então de madeira porque precisam é
muito maior agora se for usar bolinhas
da esoft é muito difícil porque as
bolinhas dispersos muito tipo tipo de
choque gana vai bala por todo lado e
você nunca sabe onde é que vai acertar
porque vocês conseguem separar
as balas ao mesmo tempo uma área muito
grande e brancos ao chegar um filme
sobre a atriz tidos vocês quiseram estar
mas é muito plano de usarem óculos
proteção têm que ser responsáveis e
fiquei contente no canal porque no
próximo vídeo vai ter um sorteio para
curar o meio milhão de inscritos de
pronto vai para agradecer a todos vocês
por apoiarem estas coisas que eu faço é
isso então obrigado até a próxima de
dilma e é aí vou estar muito porque tem
uma bala então eu vou experimentar ainda
funciona
estava não quero só marketing